let's talk about biden bill netwall we
have the story from the daily mail
biden now wants to restart construction
on trump's border wall to plug the gaps
with kids camps way over capacity and a
new surge of migrants coming from
guatemala
this is amazing joe biden actually shut
down the construction as soon as he gets
in
because people like joe biden and the
people who voted for him look
i'm trying to be nice i'll be respectful
i understand a lot of people just didn't
know what they were voting for when they
voted for biden
they hear something there's no logical
basis to it it's just an emotional
reaction
the wall is racist donald trump is the
cheeto dictator so the wall must be
stopped
so biden gets in and goes yeah come on
yo we're gonna stop the wall you gotta
you gotta you know get the straight
razor in the barrel and then bang it on
the
the fence to make it come down and then
he stops construction
and then all of a sudden we're dealing
with this massive border crisis why
because biden basically signaled to all
of these
individuals in other countries open for
business
what did biden say moratorium on
deportations for 100 days he lost that
fight but he still said it
so these people are thinking under trump
you know they're going to throw you out
at least you can try and get some media
pity
under joe biden so here they come now
joe biden has no choice
but to reopen the child detention
centers he's putting children
under bridges in mccallen texas sleeping
in dirt
and now he's going to rebuild the wall i
gotta say i wonder if the trump
supporters gonna be like
all right we'll take the win on that one
you know we were worried we weren't
gonna get the wall and now trump's gonna
build the wall so uh
how very um that's strong leadership
from joe biden right
yeah you know he actually said that he
inherited this crisis it was exactly
like this we just didn't hear about it
because the media
never would have smeared donald trump
that's right that's right never
is it because of like a global recession
that we're getting this influx of
migrants or have we always well so there
is there are seasonal waves that's true
and joe biden tried claiming there's no
crisis you know it's it's a seasonal
wave come on man
and what's actually happening because
abc i think abc and nbc
uh journalists interviewed some illegal
immigrants who are like
uh it's cause joe biden says he's gonna
be nice
and he's giving us an opportunity to
come so you actually had i can't
remember who it was
i think it might have been cnn where
they were like you can't deny this
you actually have no no i'm sorry it was
uh jonathan carl
i think he was talking to brian stelter
brian's helper of cnn was like these are
right-wing talking points
and this guy from abc is like no it
isn't our reporter went down and
the the illegal immigrant said it's
because of biden
well there you go you vote for a guy who
screws it up and now the best he can
offer is
trying to do what trump was already
doing it is true that the words of the
president have resounding
impact like when trump was like get him
out of here hit that guy or something at
a rally
and then you saw started to see this
wave of people punching people he said
something like
you know i would hit him and you know
i'll pay the legal fees or something
like that someone decked a guy at one of
his rallies so it does and if biden
mentioned that even in passing i can
imagine it would definitely be well
affecting people so
there's you know there's one of the big
problems with trump during his
presidency but he he did
stop that that was early in his
campaigns and he was like no no we can't
do that we'll let the police handle it
because he realized like
no i can't tell people to do something
like that or or or support anyway
but with donald sorry i think some of
that was going from being a celebrity
you know celebrity businessman like well
like guy friends of everybody the first
time he was ever booed was going down
that escalator never been booed in his
life
um so i think a lot of that was how he
would have behaved as you know
a personality and then being like oh my
gosh i'm i'm running for president i
can't i can't say things like that
anymore
however because of things like that
imagine what these other countries must
have been thinking
when it's like imagine you're you know
like iran or something
and they're like we need you to go and
have this meeting with donald trump and
the guy goes
what am i going to say that guy that's
crazy no matter what i say he's going to
be yelling at me it's like
i'm not getting anything done and so all
of these countries were probably on edge
every time they would meet with trump or
have to meet with the u.s
because they're like trump is just going
to demand and there's nothing you can do
to convince the guy
now they got sleepy joe now they're all
laughing and high-fiving each other and
they're like yes
so imagine what how everyone is feeling
you've got a lot of
people who want to come to come to this
country and i said this before i'll say
it again because i love saying it
i have infinitely more respect for
illegal immigrants
who are willing to crawl through you
know walk through vast swathes of desert
risking their lives going on thousand
mile journey because they think america
is that awesome
as opposed to these woke leftists who
are like america is racist and awful
our health care is awful it's like okay
tell that to the people who are dying to
come here
who are like surging at the border
so i digress these people want to come
they're regular people they clearly see
the rhetoric of donald trump was
very extreme we're going to send them
back you got to stay we're going to
build a wall and they're like
you could risk this huge journey and
they're going to they're going to kick
you out new mexico
with the remaining mexico policy now
with joe biden it's like
doors open let's roll
that's right how much more of the wall
do they have to build well biden wants
to plug up some gaps
so like how complete is it are you guys
familiar with it uh
it's about i think last the last number
i read was like seven hundred miles
i think was it seven hundred yeah and
what they tried doing was smearing trump
by saying like
uh trump proposed a big beautiful wall
30-foot concrete from sea to shining sea
and they were like you're not going to
build 2 000 whatever miles of wall
then what happens is when trump gets in
and he finally gets the funding
he starts reinforcing select areas where
there's
serious problems trafficking smuggling
etc and then they started claiming
trump's only replacing existing wall
which was the craziest lie
because the wall at the walmart air
quotes was like
two pieces like two two by fours and an
x shape with another two by four on did
you guys ever see the wall with your own
eyes
i've just seen pictures of of both i
went to tijuana south
they're right by uh south south
california and man it was
junk it was like post totally going out
into the water like
40 walk around like you could just swim
out around it and go
yeah i've been i was oh i've been to
various points on the border recently in
the past few years i was in
uh mexicali and calexico i think the
city's name
and it's really amazing how it's
actually
in in some ways rather porous legally
like people just walk back and forth
every single day like normal so like
some people from mexico are like they
walk up and they're like here's my id
it's like what are you coming for i'm
going shopping have a nice day sir and
they walk into the u.s they go shopping
and they go home where are you going i'm
going home have a nice day sir
but yeah you could see the wall and we
went a little further out
and you could see the uh i can't
remember exactly what
it's like fencing you see the trucks
driving along it well so what happened
was donald trump wanted a big concrete
wall
and i guess cbp and ice they were like
i cbp said you don't want a wall because
we need to see on the other side of it
so they're like what if we do like
fencing and then a wall on top and like
we need to see on the other side of it
they make windows
like you can walk through the wall yeah
yeah just open like a regular old window
like
sliding glass doors sliding glass
so so the media claims trump didn't
build the wall mexico obviously didn't
pay for it trump tried claiming the
trade deal was gonna you know pay for it
over
but uh he built select secure fencing
triple layered in some areas
so you've got one big fence a smaller
fence and a smaller fence
razor wire and cbp vehicles driving in
between the two
particularly secure well they were doing
construction
joe biden stopped it and then boom
border prices yeah
i heard that most migrants come in uh
via airplane i don't think that i don't
think it's most
oh but i think it's a lot okay they're
like flying to chicago
well they they fly in on tourist visas
and then stay yeah
they're never leave yeah there are a
bunch of other issues too that that are
legit
like um what do they call it uh like
what is it called pregnancy tourism or
something like that oh yeah birthday
birth terrorism yeah oh so yeah have a
baby
yeah yeah yep so a woman will be you
know
on the verge of giving birth she'll fly
here you get three to six months
depending on what your visa is
and they just wait have the kid the
kid's a citizen it could be what do you
guys think should be like the criteria
of
immigrating to the united states uh
hunger games
if you you've got to compete and the
only the person who survives gets the
citizenship
i'll watch obviously i'll i'll start it
off i think i think they should speak
english
100 you need that's my number one
really why because otherwise i just want
people to assimilate into the culture
that that is a good point assimilation
is a good point i wonder maybe if they
should
commit just to learning to speak english
like you know like
something something on those lines as
opposed to already knowing the english
wouldn't
i might have the means to learn it i i
understand the point but i kind of feel
like maybe americans should learn
more languages too and so that's racist
well saying that americans should learn
more languages you know it's a cultural
language
of cultural appropriation yes we speak
english if we learn
spanish it's cultural appropriation i
read that somewhere so it must be true
remember those ladies who were making
tacos in portland or whatever yeah and
they got shut down
and the story was like they would look
through the windows at mexican
restaurants to like see how things were
done and that was stealing and i'm like
dude
most of these restaurants just like they
have the abuelita making the
corn tortillas in front of everybody to
show you it's like real fresh
and it's just it's like corn flour and
water you know what i mean and you just
like
and you put on the thing it's just
authentic when you got the nice little
your grandma she's making it for you
i went to one place it was awesome right
when you walk in there's like the the
grill
and there was a little you know mexican
grandmother and she's smiling and waving
and she's making tortillas and i was
like
this is going to be the best taco i've
ever had but apparently i'm not supposed
to like that
oh it's crazy like you you have these
these restaurants and they're like we
want people to
you know enjoy this stuff anyway going
back to the main point
dude look we have mexican restaurants
all over the u.s it becomes a part of
our culture with a great american
melting pot
i do get your point about speaking
english because if people can't talk to
each other it's hard for them to work
together
so i saw that when i went to sweden when
you had the somali migrants and refugees
from 20 years ago
when they weren't properly integrated
they created their sort of
own community that didn't work properly
with the swedish you know like community
and so it created poverty it created
poverty it bred crime
and then the swedes were super racist
and they were like oh those people are
bad and it's like dude
you took people from a war-torn country
who are desperate good for you i
appreciate that that's a good thing to
do
but you then just dropped them in a city
center somewhere and
left and these people had no idea how to
speak swedish or get jobs
what were they supposed to do you can't
just do that
saving the people was a great idea but
it's it's like half-assed
and that's what's happening now with the
left and the open borders people they're
like let them come in
it's like okay after they come in and
there's 90 miles of desert what do we do
next
i don't know when cbp picks up this kid
and he's sick and dies they blame cbp
for it should he just let the kid die in
the desert
they give you these half answers they're
emotional there was like there was one
group of people
that put food and water randomly out in
the desert and they got arrested for it
for littering and it was this big thing
on the left where they're like
how awful are police it's so insane
they're trying to save migrants i'm like
dude
you can't go into the desert and just
put food and water on the ground and
think you're feeding someone
animals will come or you're just quite
literally putting garbage out that no
one's gonna eat
it's the craziest thing emotional uh
emotional responses
and now here we are months out and at
least joe biden's not tweeting mean
things
refugees i i find a little different i
would be okay letting refugees in where
regardless of the language they speak
because that's a that's a different
situation but immigration
that's when that's where i start to draw
the line economic migration i i hear
you're saying
i guess i guess the issue is like
in the place where i grew up everyone
spoke polish some people didn't even
speak english
you know what i mean so there there are
issues of integration if a large
portion of an area can't communicate
michigan it's pretty much like
it's it's like you oh and dear people
feel like you're going through another
country when you go through dearborn
but they speak english enough yeah and
so it works like i went to i've been a
dearborn a couple times yeah and a lot
of the businesses it's written
so they've assimilated i've never seen
it i've just we were talking about
um the swedish community and i was
wondering if america had one
i would say it was very similar in that
you go there and or at least when i went
there
there are areas where everything's in
arabic and you go to a restaurant but
they can speak english
and i had a great time i'd be completely
honest i understand maybe there are some
concerns
you know you know about maybe gangs or
extremists or whatever when i went there
went to a car wash everybody was really
nice went out to eat we went and got
mediterranean food it was amazing it was
like legit made by people who knew how
to make
you know falafel and hummus and all that
good stuff so
they're i don't know it's it is an issue
of
how can one community work with another
community or the greater community
if they don't understand each other but
i'm not entirely convinced that
that can't be navigated somehow like
it's it's the worst thing in the world
you know what i mean
i i don't think people need to i'll put
this way
i don't think they need to be fluent in
english they need to be able to
communicate we need to be able to
communicate communicate with each other
to a certain degree
so i don't know how you solve for that i
do i do agree with you on the refugee
point though
economic migrants who are coming here
for work and for jobs
should be able to interact and and work
with other people and that requires
probably a base
basic level of uh english because we are
a predominantly english speaking country
you know yeah yeah it's good to be able
to work but i also think there's a huge
part of life that is not work i
basically live for my work i really
enjoy working and i like being able to
talk to all you guys
but at the same time if you want to be
able to actually be a part of the
culture that you're in you have to be
able to speak well enough
in the language that whatever country
that you're in that you have to be able
to like go out and meet in groups you
have to be able to meet other people who
already live there
i do think that fluency is a huge
benefit to people who come to the us
i wonder if this um multiculturalism
is it's something that's been in america
for a long time and i wonder if
it's one of the reasons we see things in
the united states we don't see in other
parts of the world
in the same levels so actually that that
probably makes no sense
i was going to say like when you look at
certain police brutality instances
it's interesting if you go to a country
like sweden or norway which are
overwhelmingly white and they say oh but
we don't have these things and i'm like
perhaps there's a
you know race plays a role and there's
like some kind of racism that can go in
any direction
that doesn't exist in a homogenous
homogeneous community where they all
agree speak the same language do the
same thing
so it's not necessarily about race it's
about i guess familiarity
but i i guess my point was that in the
united states like
there are segregated neighborhoods all
over chicago it's it's
all totally segregated no joke you cross
you go from archer on the south side you
go past cicero
and the billboards are now in spanish
you go the other direction and then you
got a bunch of signs in polish
so how are these people going to you
know interact to work with each other
when they're just like very distinct and
separate
culturally morally and linguistically
i feel like that could lead to an
inability for people to come together
and work together for sure
familiarity's key like if this this
isn't a race war
if anything it's like a a class war or
familiar
like you you you tend to be afraid of
what you don't understand the unknown
you know and language plays directly
into that and
a bias towards the in-group so if you're
an english-speaking american
you have a bias towards people who are
like you and those within you know the
polish
community in chicago aren't going to be
able to branch out and work their
their jobs are in their community that's
why their community
there's no way to go up they're kind of
stuck in that
in that circle there's there's no
opportunities outside because you don't
speak the language but the older
generation
so what happens is the kids all speak
english like luke for instance
you know he's recently he was on the
show for a little bit then he just
abandoned us
because he's he's a cold callous
individual
mexico he went to florida i guess but uh
but he's born in poland he moves here he
grows up speaking english
he talks about how it was not so easy
for him because when he came here he
didn't
but then he did and now he's you know
extremely in my opinion extremely
important american defending american
values
yeah so that's why i'm like i'm not
super concerned necessarily with
you know people coming here who don't
speak the language if they can function
and they can work
and they can you know be a part of the
community their kids will grow up and
it's really just about if we're doing a
good if we're doing right by our kids
and teaching them
the you know important values however i
guess that's not something we're
doing entirely at this point a lot of
people don't want to have kids
they're talking about oh i can't raise a
kid in this environment and it's like
if you don't have kids then who's going
to have kids it's like idiocracy you
know well a lot of it too
they're they're excusing themselves to
be able to extend their own childhood
yeah you know a lot of it is not that
they they don't want kids maybe in a
different
life they'd want kids but right now
they're very it's it's a me generation
it's very it's the most selfish
generation
i think i think the idea of childhood is
a modern creation
so it's interesting when i remember who
was a republican was like kids need
jobs and then the democrats were like
you want to go back to the 1900s putting
kids in factories and it's like
no but kids should do work with
family but more than that like uh
i think kids should paper spend more
time
seeing what their parents do for a
living understanding the real world
and we should be treating kids like
adults the problem is as
generation of generation has has you
know come and gone
it seems like it used to be if you had a
kid
the kid had to grow up fast there was
war there was death there was famine
stop crying you're 13 you're a man now
and that's like pretty brutal and we're
like nah like we want to be
like kind of chill but we keep pampering
the next generation oh yeah now it's
like kids are
i say kids now you got people who are 26
years old and they're like
just getting out of college and they've
never had a job in their lives it's like
dude you're 26.
amazing i i learned how to cook when i
was 14. i didn't even realize this i
just realized this a couple days ago
because i'm i'm a bit of a chef a cook i
love cooking i love the smell making
things
and i used to work at a chicken shack
when i was 14. i think that directly
contributed to my ability to understand
food i didn't even think of that but
you gotta you gotta learn teach you
learn young too dude when i went to
south america the kids would like be
boat captains at the age of nine you'd
go down the
the amazon with the atari and they'd be
like full-on running the show
nine-year-olds imagine being like 15
from one of these countries you come to
the united states and you've been a boat
captain running your own business
and then you come here and you see all
these 15 year olds like sitting around
picking their nose and you're like wow
what are you doing
how are these people gonna like you know
what it is man it is
it is capital city hunger games man
affluenza
it is yeah yeah americans in general are
suffering from affluenza actually a
judge
adjudicated that affluenza was a thing
right but listen
that's like the specific case it's kind
of like i roll my eyes that
that ruling's ridiculous but think about
americans in general 15 year old 16 year
old 17 18 year olds
who don't have jobs and never did i had
a job at 14
and before that i was volunteer at the
ymca what was your job of 14
uh fast food perfect yep 14 14
but how are you how are you legally
allowed to do that because you could
work at 14. i'm i'm older than i look
like a worker's permit yeah when did
they change the law to be that you had
to be 16.
shortly after i started working oh even
with a workers permit
i was able to i don't know actually i
didn't get a workers permit i worked my
family business
oh yeah when i was really young so yeah
and a lot of work at the table
kids like i mean i come from a family a
lot of them live up in
uh pearl vermont and they all own farms
and those kids have been you know
collected eggs from the chicken since
they were five you know you gotta my
first job
yeah you gotta you gotta have a sort of
responsibility a personal responsibility
to become a you know well-rounded person
when you don't you end up with a bunch
of woke
me first you lack you end up lacking
responsibility and accountability and
that's kind of why
america is in chaos right now no one
takes any responsibility for what they
do
that's why it's crazy to me when when
people come over off gas and they'll be
like
they'll look at my work schedule and be
like you're crazy and i'm like
i think you're crazy man like no offense
to some of these people but like
i i i used to work every weekend as well
now weekend is partially administrative
with some time off to relax go out to
eat or whatever
but it's like i work you know eight to
four and then i work seven to eleven
every day and in between all i'm doing
is like eating or exercising it's like
all of my time is consumed
and i'm like what would i do if i wasn't
working like what do you do for fun
i don't know like what do you mean you
don't know do you like just sit there
yeah meditation no no you blank out
you blanked your mind it's awesome
that's weird you get younger weird to me
regeneration
i don't know about that yeah i i think
you have a hobby and you do your hobby
and
i mean you raise your family if you have
a family
yeah i mean i know there's a lot of
people without purpose
and so that's that's kind of a cancer
right now in america too because
they think they find a purpose is
something you just want to commit your
life to like a lot of people
especially the older generations their
purpose is their family
they have you know they've set money
aside they just dote on their family
they
they love their family they spend time
with their family but you get a younger
generation and
their purpose is the next big drama
and that's their they commit their whole
life to this this is they're gonna go to
protest the wall and that's just their
that's their purpose that's their whole
life they put everything into it until
that passes and their purpose is gone so
then they have that drop
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you